Mark: Blue snooze
Bob: [sneezes in auto tune]
*everyone laughing* (Bob: Oh, fuck.)
B: That's not how I thought that was going to sou-
Mark: Ahahahah!
B: That was a good sound, I think I need that sound....(Mark continues laughing hysterically)
M: That was amazing
M: I really like that - ahahaha
B: You gonna make the game Wade so I don't do the thing that enrages you?
Which I don't know what that is.  But I assume I would do it accidentally.
Wade: Yea I wanna avoid that thing.
M: Yea come on invite me
B: Also does your audio still do the nonsense or-
B: Okay, cool. Wow, they really teach you everything! (slap effect)
W: I threw - I threw money at the problem and the problem went away!
M: Wh - no one said we had to.
B: We can do regular Uno.
M: Yeah, what if we just do plain old Uno?
W: Oh you want to do Regular Uno?
B: Regular Uno.
M: Why does it have to be weird?
B: Just- Just heck it, y'know?
W: It doesn't! The- The- Barbara's only on Rayman so I'm perfectly [BLEEP] fine with this.
M: Don't curse!!
B: [deep voice] Gosh darn it!
B: [normal voice] Ugh, that's not even the right voice.
B: [deep auto tune voice] Gosh darn it.
M: Can you stop cursing? My monetization....
M: I- I don't do my intros..
M: Hello everybody.
B: F*** !! (censored)
*laughter*
M: Alright cool, good. You know that's fine.
M: Can I get in the gosh darn game ?
B: Oh that's right, my picture is me fleacking you off.
W: Oh.
B: I forgot about th-
M: MY MONETOZATION !!!
B: Maybe it's my pointer fingers, you can't see most of my hand,
maybe I have Simpson hands.
M: Heeee...noo I don't...
B: I might have three fingers on my hand !
M: Well, unless you have your wedding band on your middle finger,
and your pinky finger is cut off..
B: Yeah, no that's it.
M: Ok, alright, that's fair. That's- That's fair.
B: It's no- it's not offensive.
M: It's just like "look at my brain !"
"Look at my big brain !"
B: "Look at my huge heaaad !"
M: All right-
B: Brain head !
B: That other head, not the peni..
M: I wasn't even thinking penis-
Guys, I wanna make money on this !
B: Guys, I wasn't even thinking of the penis head, ok ?
Stop it !
M: I need.. I'm just alwa-
B: Stop it !
M: I got money on my mind !
W: I'vE gOt MoNeY iN tHe BaNk
W: Right ? You guys..
B: What ?
M: What ?
M: Was tha- that supposed to be like, Old Town Road ?
W: Maybe.
B: ♪ Old Town Roaad, Take me hom- ♪
I love that song.
W: California !
B: No, that's not it...
M: I think that was it.
W: ooook
B: Wade, I'm gonna dooo-
M: Yeah Wade, you can go now.
W: You did me a huge favor cuz I don't have any of those cards,
so I'm gonna draw.. *sad laugh*
B: Wow.
W: I, Bob what color you want? I'll give you that.
B: It doesn't really matter does it ?
M: It matters !
M: HAAAAA
M: Ah, wait wait, hang on, wait wait, wait a minute !
Wait a minute, Wade I'd challenge if I were you !
B: No don't challenge it, just let him do-
B: Rekt !
M: Oh, ooh, woho
B: Yeah, Mark-
W: I lost the challenge guys, just so you know if you didn't notice.
Bob: Get em
Bob: Get em, Wade
Mark: Get em, Wade. Get em, Wade!
Bob: Fetch em
Bob: Go get that snack,
Wade: He's gonna get this full... Hand
Mark: Nice! Bob: Oh Yeah!
Bob: So Sick!
Wade: Hell. yeahhh
Mark: Alrighhtt
Bob: Ahh, good-- wha-- um..
Bob: Well, that's w---
Bob: --Thanks buddy!!
Wade: I didn't know you didn't have any blue. Oh, there we go. Yellow
Mark: Alright cool
Bob: Now someone's gonna pay for it
Mark: Here we goo
Bob: Ohhhh snap
Wade: *faintly* I thought you were my friend (?)
Mark: I know right?
Bob: Ohhhh snAaapP
Wade: Ohhh Bob you've never been my frienndd
Bob: Okayyy that hand is terrible it's not gonna be like this for very long at all
Wade: *incomprehensible*
Mark: Alright-- wait hang on, no one's,, my friend??
Bob: Mark, you've always been my-- well never mind. *a lot of angry gibberish* Mark, I don't like you anymore
Mark: What's wrong with me??
B/W?: Grr, darn. Gosh darn it.
Mark: ..I didn't do anything to you
BOb: I'm so mad at you mark, I'm gonna do that.
Mark: Why--
Wade: OH!!
Bob: because I knew that would happen!!
Mark: hEYY
Bob: *scared* oh oH OH
Wade: GOTCHYA, GOTCHYA BI--
Wade: You dirty, dirty, da- uh-- *incomprehensible*
Mark: Don't you dare curse.
Wade: I didn't! I stopped myself for you.
Mark: Thank you--
Bob: F***
Mark: You're just making a Lixian do work. That's all you're doing
Wade: Oh, after me? No. After YOU
Bob: Well, that's not so good.
Wade: *whispering* It's not good for me either if I'm being honest.
Wade: NOOO my hEArTT
Bob: *audible confusion*
Wade: IT's BRoKEn
Bob: Calm down with that. Oh boy. Oh, man. I can't I can't do anything about that
Mark: but I can do something about thIS
Bob: Alrigghtt
Wade: AYYY CHOMPER. MY MAN
Mark: Uhhh
Bob: Wow, that's just rude, Chomper
Wade: That's what happens. You don't have the Barbara Wade get the chance..
Wade: ..To do a little dance
Mark: What happened to all the cards that just make the game all- all crap and..
Bob: I know--
*more incomprehensible speaking*
Bob: Why is this like this, Wade? Who did this?
Wade: *Aggresssive exhaling*
Mark: ha HA
Wade: you wouldn't like Wade when he angry
Bob: I can jump in on myself! I can--
Mark: *wheeze, then laughter*
Bob: Why didn't it-- I was click-- I was clicking it--
Mark: Jump in on THIS, Bob.
Bob: That's soooooo rude
Mark: *maniacal laughter*
Wade: Oh gosh, diddly darn I got this one at least.
Bob: Wait. So are we full- Are we, are we not supposed to curse?
Mark: Well, I mean..
Wade: *whispering* I don't know--
Bob: Is it bad for monitization--
Mark: YEs it is. Yes it is.
Mark: If you do any cursing at all--
Anything--
Bob: Straight up...
Bob: How light- how lightweight does it have to be
Mark: That sound like, in certain lights, that sounds bad..
..But I guess that's okay.
Bob: But it-- but was-- that's uhh that's a PG--
Wade: *angry* Ohhhhh you..
Wade: ....friend of minneeee
Bob: How many times do I have to kiss you!
Mark: oh you
Mark: you frickin--
Wade: Oh, one more time
Mark, continuing his insult: Sassy..
Wade, still angry: oNE mOre TimE
Bob: You apple that fell off the tree
*angry noises*
Wade: aAAAaa I clicked itttt
Mark: You poopy headed--
Bob and Wade: *unintelligible*
Mark: You mustache-wearing---
I will do this
*just a lot of wheezes and ridiculous insults
Bob: Wendy's window assistant yeah, that's what it's called
Mark: You the large poured-- uhh--
--Red-nosed freak!!
Bob: Whoa. Whoa. That's harsh man
Wade: You left me choice but to play this..
five... *snickers*
Bob: You showed me man.
Bob: Just-- whooh.. Fatal.
Wade: my brain was like don't say just five. Don't say just five
Bob: I looked up and then was was was showered with that one
You.. You.. Pickle pusher..
Red-haired truck.. drdj.. driver.
You did it again! You.. You long necked..
aAAAAAAAAAAAhhh..
Ha ha to whoever's getting this!
E..Ear wax.. Eater! *sigh* This is hard.
You know what, Bob? Here's what I think of our friendship!
d'OOwwww....
You small footed..
Lunch budger. OHHHH you!
Hey don't even- OOOOOOOOOOOOOW YOU WOULD, you.. you... Flappy eared..
Nipple squeezeeer! That's right, it was all part of my perfect ploy to take your card!
Anyway, that's a green party plane
Changes I can't I can't you know
cards
Come on in whose eyes anyway, every time they play the euphemism game Colin Mochrie is like great God
You green card played you
butter stick eating backwards walking
Cartoon watcher that's right, Bob Bob
Belly basher
What is this hand I had like four eights last hand to start with so
I wouldnt dream of it
Can't but I would dream of it
Table liquor yeah, you're the one who played the dreaded thing you well
wiping poop step
for card taking card taker
You're the crushing it man you crested it thanks Oh Bob. I've got another round of hate for you you
You card get a guy to my left
Yeah, I can jump in on my own card, hey it worked that time I feel like somehow in this I'm so
Scared of accidentally saying something really horrible
I'm glad my
Fault it's not my fault
You gave me this card that I will pass on. Oh, wait a minute. Hang on you
Sneaky brain. Okay. That's right. They took
Cards, well, it didn't help me
Cars, all right
Well, I'm jumping in
All right, get that one. No, I'm good
Wow great
Great, why would you do that? I had three plus fours from the start now, they all gone all gone
They all gone they all gone
well
when
Licking dill herder. Oh boy. Oh darn it Wow
Well, geez, that's not even a good one red
okay, I don't know my colors very
Colored changing colour what there?
We're all we can all enjoy that, you know what to do with it. I think you know what to do Wade. I
Think you know what to do. Yes
You go slapping
Obviously not Wow sucks even more than that hand. I'm not sure what happened but it seems like it worked out for me
How did you draw cards and then jump in on your own car because I already had the red forest
Wanted to get a seven or a zero get rid of this
Yeah, well, you know, I really expected this to be the winning hand
Stabbed him right in the throat. Yeah
Listen I reverse that at you
No, I wish there was a game mode actually reverse
That I'm gonna take that Elmo
Well, it's not my thoughts out of my hands out of
Jerkhole ruin that for everyone no. No I was
Don't yeah, I have one
Right now
Okay, well alright get a mark, I'll be here
That's really worked out
Okay, you know what I don't care
How nice of you kind of okay
Darn it
Wait I even with all yeah, I
Know that that that hands fine leave Acadia keeps going back to read that hand doesn't have anymore. There's so many of that
Wait, okay. I accept this I
Forgot your judgment, sir. Do not accept it
That was the one Bob that's the one that's the funny thing about that that's the
All right mark you were down to two cars before weren't you sure was yeah you were
Well, thanks man, thank you they you good I know you like these green I do I do it's my favorite. Well, it's not
Mushroom wielder there now you can insult now you can yeah
I don't have any blue and I find that it's not my fault is
It makes sense now you drew that one I see that now
I wasn't thinking about
What hang on I play for against that? Oh
Boy take it to the face. We got a lot of cards
These cards, alright, I dare you to play it on yourself
Look mark, I want you to have the same kind of
Wait
Seven Chomper you game wrong?
Absolutely, hi-yah. Oh no. Oh, thank you
Yeah, that's a four buddy. You did it. Thanks man, Oh
Chopper you don't get to play after you broke the rules of the game that aggressive. Yeah, I know. I'm sorry
I should have been more like hey Chomper, I'm sorry
You can't stop by insult you
Daddy doesn't like this game
What game
Specifically is that you don't like the game of changing hands with?
Chomper I feel like you've been on ironically calling yourself daddy a lot more lately
I'm not a father Oh daddy. It's just a sexual term. I want you to refer to me as from now on and
Monetize oh god. Damn it Oh
Participa. Well, that's rude. Oh that stinks
That's just I'm gonna challenge it just because it's so man only Reds
Wow, he's got only red cards everyone. Don't spoiler alert. You're ruining the ending
Hey you go mark that don't show him
Oh did I now
You got destroyed
Shoppers good why is chopper good at this game as many rensis - well, that's not the way I need to word it, huh?
Huh? Huh guys, I had I had it in the bag guys
Wait, that's not my bag Bob. That's not your bag, man, my bag
Right reverse it
I have a thing I can do with some stuff with the cards that I have in my hand if you reverse it Chomper
Kind of rude, and I apologize
Listen, I know what you're thinking. Oh man. I challenge you to a duel sir
My dueling weapon that I won't show on camera has been out this whole time
You're family-friendly dueling weapon. Yes
Okay, I could do something else
You can definitely crush him Rex next row, don't worry you have so many cartage
To go put it blue put a blue wait put a blue. Yes
I'm not gonna do anything miss around you do. Okay. Watch this
See this. Ah, yeah, see now watch, you know, watch it now watch. Yeah. See I've got no blue in
14 cards, I have no blue that's impressive. I know right for how
Lost my amounts of red Oh God one would think
For how many cards do you do hat? Well, that's just rude Bob. There is ZERO red in this hand now we were working together
Oh why me, I don't have me I
See what he's going at. I see what he's getting at
Here - my eyes. Got some moves guys, Bob Bob take a look at this hand. Just take a look at it
There's a problem. You can't really get around in that hand. You just got yourself there
Here, I'll let you get around it right now
Yeah, hold out of the bag he's gonna chomp on his own grave soon right guys probably
Listen chopper, you're gonna have something - well, yeah chopper is like real douchebag right now. Yeah
Let's see if they doing right now he's got he's got a whole
Well, that was my one trick I had in the bag and now the bag is just full of garbage
Wait, look at my bag. Did you see that bag?
I was like a reusable bag, okay
Okay, make it yellow. Yeah, I would totally would do that for you if I could no
No for not for me make chopper to play that 70s to give up his hand to one of us. Sure. Yeah, well
Slowly becoming absolute trash
All right, good thing one of us has a good and around here. I'm gonna draw some more cards because I want to
Because I don't have anything that
I'll take this. Oh, thanks. Oh, that's not the direction. I thought it was traveling Oh
EE shocked by which hand I ended up with and then what was it?
Buddy ol pal, you're sure making me have to empty it out. Okay. I'll just keep emptying the tank
It's okay because I got my own trick play
Blue suede I don't think you have anything but I'm doing this because I felt like it not because I had to
Oh you want to make sure you get the right one, you know
Okay, that's an option that we had before
Joyce Bob listen to me. All right
Mom I didn't have a choice
That's great
Bob what color you need? I mean, I'd like to keep it. Okay. Thanks
And I know you didn't have to do
The fun of this game is playing it so the longer you get to play it the more fun you
Is out of spite oh, well that's not what you want to see hey wait you got a joke for you. You're gonna laugh
No, no, no, no you don't get it. You know what's happening?
Yeah, what's up, I'm ready I'm ready I'll jump here we go. Yeah, uh-huh. I got this spoon
Okay, well just make it read and get over with all you think should be read oh you silly fool it's gonna be
What color do you want? Oh, you know, maybe we could do yellow or blue, right? Okay. Cool. Good good. Thank you
I I'm a good friend. All right, well, I don't trust you
What I drew that I listen. I know I'm not a psychopath open
I'm gonna give you the sand is whatever you would have automatically won the round if I had the color
No, I'm gonna I know I want more cars to give you this. That's my strategy then I mark your age. Yeah, I'm gonna jump
here we go
Mark and a lot of cards did actually it's true